also as president Trump tries to secure
our southern border Democrats continue
to demonize agents and Senator Kamala
Harris said this just last week at the
confirmation hearing for Trump's pick to
lead eyes take a look take a look at
this outraged Klan was a what we would
call today a domestic terrorist group
why why why would we call them domestic
terrorist group because they tried to
use fear and force to change political
environment and what was the motivation
for the use of fear influence based on
race and ethnicity right are you aware
of the perception of many about how the
the the power and the discretion a dice
is being used to enforce the laws and do
you see any parallels I do not see any
parallels between I'm talking about
press officers and agents I'm talking
about perception I do not see a parallel
the perception of ice being the KKK here
with reaction Fox News contributor Tammy
Bruce and former acting ice director Fox
News contributor Thomas Holman is with
us I don't know how you react to Tammy
reacted Camela Harris sir but number one
I like your reaction and number two I
think more importantly you see what's
beginning to boil over in Tijuana and I
don't see any good answers here and the
people in Mexico using Donald Trump's
verbage language the feeling that this
is an invasion and it comes at a great
cost to them because their borders were
not respected their law is not respected
well first of all come out of Harris
what she did was disgusting I mean she
compared to 20,000 men and women of ice
the same men and women that lead the
safety and security of their home every
day strapped a gun to the hip and defend
this nation to compare them to the two
such a hate group is just disgusting and
you know and for her as a u.s. senator
to make that comparison with her herself
need to look in the mirror she failed
the American people ice is enforcing the
laws that Congress enacted they're not
making this up
so she would have done her job and close
the loopholes that cause illegal
immigration we wouldn't have this
Caravan today so shame on her
and I've said it once before she should
go walk to national law enforcement
memorial and apologize all the fallen
boards ladies and Ice Ages that gave
their lives for this country
she is disgusting on what she did as far
as what's going on Tijuana yeah that's
right as long as Tijuana look we got a
great president
we got a president takes border security
seriously we got a president that
believes in the sovereignty in this
country we got a president that believes
in the rule of law we got a present that
supports the Borgo a nice he's doing his
job so what's going on in Mexico as you
said Shawn they're waking up their
country had their sovereignty has been
attacked these people went through their
southern border assaulted their federal
officers and their military Mexico
finally saying enough is enough and the
reason this is coming to the head
because President Trump has taken power
she's know what our borders closed for
illegal business
so what he's done is forces his Caravan
to be stuck in Tijuana
he put this issue on the front burner
he's a great press he's been right and
everything he's done this border and I'm
certainly glad he's there and now
everybody's talking about it and we're
gonna be successful in this you know
Tammy you got protesters in Tijuana
erupting Trump was right this is an
invasion 500 criminals are Department of
Homeland Security point out I've mixed
in with those that perhaps just want a
better life which I'm assuming Mexico is
not prepared to deal with any of this
and now it's gotten to the point we've
got thousands of people and no place to
go which was being laughed at by people
like Barack Obama and Democrats before
the election this is just fear-mongering
apparently it doesn't look like it yeah
it doesn't and look a lot of those
people we think it's possible removed to
try to access the United States to
Tijuana
because the drug cartels are unhappy
because of the most rudimentary steps
we've actually taken razor wire some you
know impediments at the border to keep
people from being able to come over has
affected the ability to move drugs into
the country
imagine the success we'd have if there
was a wall 64,000 deaths from heroin and
other opioids are doses but primarily
heroin in this country in 2016 64,000
Dead Americans at the very least that's
the reason why we should secure the
border in this regard and regarding
Kamala Harris speaking about the
trafficking into the interior ice is the
organization that saves lives that
protects the lives of the immigrant
communities legal and illegal it doesn't
matter when they deal with ms-13 the sex
trafficking the drug trafficking the
efforts to kidnap children to force them
into the gangs to force them into drug
abuse it is ice that gets the criminals
who are stopping that activity and for
Kamala Harris to suggest that those
individuals who risk their lives to save
the lives of the immigrant communities
and also the lives of people in the
urban areas is obscene and it highlights
the fraud that the Democrats are now and
especially the women who are claiming to
be feminists leading that party they are
condemning girls and women in the
process of this rhetoric to create more
divisions we should all reject it
powerful Tammy thank you Thomas thank
you